well since the beginning of the year
once a week we are doing a couple of
segments with my daughter Rachel Cruz
she's joining me as we talk about
parenting with your money
she and I written a book together that
comes out in April called smart money
smart kids and so together we've been
talking to parents and to aunts and
uncles about how to raise money smart
kids to teach the next generation how to
win Rachel's joining me again and we get
to talk about a fun one today and this
is in the book we address this in the
book and actually I don't remember if it
was Rachel's idea or mine did I put it
in the book but it's a good idea who's
ever idea it was I'll take credit
talking about weddings well welcome back
yeah you could take credit because your
wedding you know you and your sister I
think we did pretty good with weddings
at the Ramsey household number one we
don't do bridezilla we don't put up with
human beings acting that way any of us
Ramsey's your mom you me none of us we
just don't think that way that crazy
spoiled brat syndrome thing but then too
we had a system and we went at it and
and it turned into just a wonderful
celebration but we will come back to
that I guess so weddings how do you deal
with it because this book is about smart
money smart kids about teaching your
kids about money three to 33 so moms and
dads listen up how do you do this
because I can tell you this Rachel in
Denise had a a some play clothes and it
was like a Halloween outfit or something
but I can see it just as clear I can
even see what was torn on it they had
this little 4 foot tall wedding dress
three foot tall two and a half foot tall
wedding dress that had been like a
Halloween costume bride wedding dress or
something and they played bride every
day growing up I don't know if every
little girl does that but those two
girls played bride every day so mom and
dad you better get ready when you start
thinking about the money for this kid
that's been playing bride every day
because when they get ready to be a
bride it could turn into bridezilla if
you don't have a plan right yeah
absolutely but I mean as a girl that's
one of the events in life that you dream
about when you dream about your wedding
day and so how to do that in a healthy
manner know
obviously your wedding days one day and
so I think that's one thing you and Mom
helped us with was saying you know
marriage is for a lifetime this is for
one day so you can't get too caught up
in it but how do you take this day and
celebrate and how do you do it in a
reasonable manner especially when it
comes to to money absolutely now you and
Rachel I mean you and Winston your
husband when you guys came in and uh you
know we approved Winston we gave him our
blessing and the big engagement happened
and and then we sat down started talking
wedding plans Oh Winston had a little
different experience didn't he he had a
different experience what does that mean
I mean he was him from you two working
together to prepare the budget okay you
know I don't know if he really saw all
of that coming well one thing that mom
and dad did with us which I was so
thankful for was obviously we were not
given a blank check and saying you know
go sweetie go do whatever you want spend
any amount of money you want that was
not obviously the case in Ramsey's a
wedding not Congress yeah exactly so so
you guys gave us a budget and thankfully
gave us a gift of money instead okay
this is the amount of money you have to
spend on the wedding and you actually
went a little bit further when you said
a lot of parents have done this is what
I've heard that anything extra you have
you get to keep and so my husband being
the saver
you know said okay well let's keep
eczema we'll save that amount we'll
spend the rest on the wedding and I
wasn't too fond of that idea because I
enjoy spending money and it was my
wedding and so we had a nice goal to
save some of the money but eventually we
spent it all and a little bit more so we
can go into that mistake that I made
with the budget so Winston I had to sit
down together and budget out our wedding
and obviously I took the reins on a
little bit more because I was the girl
and worked with the wedding planner and
you know got into the details of it
because no man it's probably torture for
most men so but yeah that was like one
of our first big learning experience is
working together with a set amount of
money on a budget and you know it was a
little bit of a gut check for me for
about a half a second not much longer
but about a half a second when I'm
writing a check that size because there
was a nice wedding and I'm handing this
cheque to you too and you and Winston
aren't married and I'm putting his name
on the account and you're
on the account and it's like do I trust
this guy this much and then I went wait
a minute I'm giving him my daughter a
better trustee of that much you know but
the money made me stop and go wow this
is real I got to trust this guy yeah I
really gotta trust him because he's
taking Rachel so but I mean there was an
interesting thing as a dad to just go
wait a second that was a little drive by
emotional experience right there and
then I went yeah I do because Winston
obviously is awesome and and you know
both of our daughters married very well
they did really well so um and we did we
set an amount and you had you guys meet
with the wedding planner explain to them
the budget and that that we're sticking
to it and this is all we've got
and then what happened you know for how
did you go I went over I did I honestly
don't know how it happens obviously I'm
not a very detailed person and so the
last thing to buy I remember was the
chairs at the reception we had to rent
those from a company and when I went
back to the account to get money out for
these chairs there was like 25 dollars
left in the account and I freaked out of
course went into full-blown
Drama mode and it did actually I thought
very well because I went back and I cut
a lot of things like transportation from
the church the reception you know I cut
that I cut a lot of the flowers I did
lots of cutting to try to get this and
Wilson helped oh yeah absolutely yeah
he kind of was like Rachel I was like I
know I know I just spent money and I
didn't stop so um that was a it was a
tough call because yeah this was one of
the mistakes I made you would think that
Dave Ramsey's kids are perfect budgeting
robots but we're not we are human beings
and and so sadly you know I didn't I cut
as much as I could and I just was you
know I was still short a little bit of a
mouse I've gained a lot of ground but I
had to make the humbling phone call to
mom and dad to say hey I need a little
bit more money to finish out the
reception and so I think that was one of
the good stories there's a lot of
stories in the book we talked about but
also through childhood that mom and dad
made us learn hard lessons but there's
also grace involved as well with parents
and so I think that's one balance you
and Mom had
and really well and this was one of
those moments of grace and and you did
help me out with a very stern lecture
over the phone but yeah you came through
at the end well you had cut your budget
you've done a lot of moves to fix it
number one and you know you really were
not out of control it was like three
percent or something it really wasn't
much money but it was enough for two
broke college students that you all
couldn't cover it and so you know I'm
going hey I'm like the guy was the movie
father the bride I'm going cheaper
chicken get the cheaper chicken right
and uh so but now but I knew I was going
to have to eat the cheaper chicken too
so that was part of it because I'm going
to this party myself and we fully intend
to have a party after a wedding our
receptions are our fun and it's it's a
cool thing so that's the first thing is
put a realistic number in place and then
really what you've got to do is you have
to back into then the actual game plan
and you know we did some budgeting
wedding budget ratios on a national
level a little bit of research that we
stuck into the book and the average
house average wedding in the u.s. right
now is running about $28,000 average
household incomes about $52,000 so the
you know that just kind of tells you
that the average wedding is about half
of an annual income that's a lot and so
if you want to be above average then you
would spend less than half your annual
income that's from the dads perspective
from the daughters perspective that
would be below average so you know you
got a look at that but that's the
averages it doesn't mean you have to
spend that much but you know if you're
talking about spending thirty thousand
bucks on a wedding and you know and you
make forty thousand that's just
ridiculous it's just you're completely
out of control and you know well our
family well I don't give a rip about
your family your family's like screw
excluded from math and so that's the
thing and there is and I'll say
encouragement on that side that if you
don't have a lot of money to budget
there's you know wonderful things like
Pinterest I mean there's so many
weddings I've gone to in the past couple
years that people have a very small
amount of money to work with but it ends
up being an incredible day because
you're just creative and so I think
that's one thing that our generation
does so well act
as you kind of think outside the box and
you're able to still have a great
wedding oh absolutely that's just the
averages and then typically the
reception is fifty five percent the
ceremony's twelve percent
photography's ten percent use a wedding
planner they're ten percent dress and a
tux is around eight percent and the rest
of the miscellaneous is around five
percent that budget by the way is in the
book smart money smart kids the book
hits the streets on April the 22nd it is
on sale now as a pre-sale and we're
throwing in fifty dollars worth of
goodies the e-book the audio book and
the DVD are the audio as well just go to
Dave Ramsey com to make your purchase
you